Here's an example of a study that Dr Laraway did. He looked at the relationship
between religiosity and self-esteem, as the two predictor variables, with the
number of days in the last month that college students reported drinking
alcohol. Just for some definitions, religiosity refers to a person's overall
level of religious feelings, practices and attitudes. Self esteem refers to
what extent a person feels that he or she if valuable, good or worthy. Higher
scores for these two predictor variables indicate higher levels of these
characteristics. His sample included 203 participants. When doctor Laraway did
the regression, he got that the y intercept was 2.763. This tells us the
predicted number of days that the participants used alcohol in the last month,
when their self esteem and religiosity were both zero. Here are the regression
coefficients that he got. Based on these, fill in the blanks. Each of these
blanks are numbers multiplied by the variable.